-Remise d'un rapport
sur une question personnelle
et universelle.
Musique intrigante
-Nous avons mené
31 auditions.
Nous avons écouté
beaucoup d'acteurs
de l'accompagnement
de la fin de vie.
Cette loi,
qui a déjà sept ans,
n'avait jamais été évaluée
par des parlementaires.
Force est de constater
qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des situations
douloureuses
et qui ne sont pas suffisamment
bien prises en charge.
...
Bonjour,
je suis Olivier Falorni,
député de la Charente-Maritime,
et je préside
la mission d'évaluation
de la loi sur la fin de vie,
dite loi Claeys-Leonetti.
-Pendant deux mois,
nous avons suivi Olivier Falorni
dans sa mission.
Hôpital de Juvisy,
en région parisienne.
Une des unités de soins palliatifs
visitée par Olivier Falorni.
-Bonjour, madame.
-Il en existe 170 en France.
Avec deux autres députés,
ils vont evaluer
si la façon dont on meurt,
aujourd'hui, dans notre pays,
est acceptable.
-Bienvenue.
-Didier Martin.
-Bonjour.
-Le rapporteur de la mission.
-En 20 ans,
la France
s'est dotée de quatre lois
sur le fin de vie.
La dernière date de 2016.
-Notre rôle, c'est évaluer
l'application de la loi
Claeys-Leonetti,
d'en voir les failles éventuelles.
Nous voulons faire en sorte
que l'accompagnement
de la fin de vie soit le plus doux
et respectueux possible.
-Un simple inventaire du service
suffit pour comprendre
l'un des problèmes majeurs
de la prise en charge
de la fin de vie.
-Deux praticiens hospitaliers
à temps plein.
-Deux praticiens,
en théorie.
-C'est ce qu'on devrait avoir.
Elle est toute seule,
et elle s'occupe
d'une autre unité.
-Côté infirmières,
en 10 ans, les effectifs
ont fondu.
-Quand je suis arrivée, il y avait
beaucoup plus de soignants.
Il y avait aucun patient
qui décédait seul.
Quand il y avait un patient
qui était en train de partir,
on se détachait.
Petit à petit,
ce nombre a diminué.
Maintenant,
on est deux par jour.
J'enlève mon masque.
Maintenant, quand il y a un patient
qui est en train de partir,
c'est difficile de se détacher
parce que la collègue reste
toute seule pour 10 patients.
-Persiste ce sentiment
de ne pas faire
son travail correctement.
Ce matin, une patiente
a tout a coup montré
des signes de tristesse.
-J'ai même dit à mes collègues :
"Il faut qu'on passe souvent
"parce qu'on voit qu'elle est bien
quand il y a quelqu'un."
Ce matin, elle n'était pas bien.
On a fini la toilette,
on est parties.
On est revenues
juste après une toilette,
elle était décédée.
Cette dame serait
peut-être mieux décédée
si elle avait eu
quelqu'un à côté d'elle,
peut-être même mourir
avec le sourire.
Ca, ça m'a fait mal au coeur,
ce matin.
-Je voulais vous poser
une question très directe.
Est-ce qu'il y a des situations
où malgré tout,
les douleurs sont réfractaires
à tout traitement ?
-Oui, ça arrive.
-Oui.
-En phase terminale,
quand la patient souffre trop,
la loi Claeys-Leonetti
a introduit un laisser-mourir
sans permettre le faire-mourir.
-Est-ce que vous pratiquez
régulièrement ou pas
ce nouveau droit
de la sédation profonde
jusqu'au décès ?
-Face à une souffrance,
on est obligés,
à un certain stade, de passer
aux pratiques de la sédation.
-La sédation consiste à endormir
un malade et à ne plus le nourrir
ni l'hydrater jusqu'au décès,
mais parfois,
il n'en finit plus de mourir.
Une situation pas toujours
bien vécue par les familles,
une des limites de la loi.
-Vous avez pris la décision,
patient conscient,
cancer métastatique,
stade terminal, etc.,
les proches sont informés,
ils passent un moment ensemble.
On se dit au revoir.
On peut mettre en place la sédation.
Si au bout de trois jours,
les choses sont toujours stables,
que le malade dort,
qu'il ne souffre pas trop,
vous continuez ou vous augmentez
les doses ?
-On continue.
Si le patient est stable,
on dépasse pas
les doses nécessaires.
-On va pas le forcer à partir
du moment où le patient
est confortable et qu'il y a
aucun signe de souffrance.
Dans quel but, en fait ?
-La sédation peut durer
un certain temps,
ça peut être des semaines.
Ca nous est déjà arrivé,
des familles qui nous demandent :
"Vous pouvez pas faire
quelque chose ?
"Pousser les seringues ?"
Non, désolée, ils auront pas
de réponse favorable chez nous.
-Ici, on n'utilise que trois
à quatre fois la sédation
chaque année sur les 200 patients
accueillis,
et une autorisation
à l'aide active à mourir
semble impensable.
-Moi, injecter un produit létal,
j'aurais mauvaise conscience.
C'est pas à moi de donner la mort
à quelqu'un
alors que j'ai signé
pour prendre soin de l'autre,
et pas pour le faire mourir.
-Peut-être que la loi évoluera
vers le suicide assisté.
Le lieu des soins palliatifs,
en tout cas l'hospitalisation
en soins palliatifs,
ne sera pas forcément le lieu
où ces choses-là
devront se pratiquer.
-C'est entendu.
-C'est ce message
qu'on essaie de vous passer,
parce que notre mission
n'est pas celle-là,
en tout cas pour l'instant.
-Pourtant, du côté des patients,
cette demande
d'étendre la loi existe.
Les députés ne verront
qu'un seul malade du service,
mais spontanément,
c'est lui même qui va aborder
ce sujet avec eux.
-Bonjour, monsieur.
Olivier Falorni.
Nous sommes députés
tous les deux.
Est-ce qu'il y a des moments
où vous sentez
que vous souffre trop ?
-Est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il faudrait faire une loi
pour les personnes qui sont
dans la même situation que vous ?
-Quelle loi il faudrait faire ?
-Si elle décide quoi, monsieur ?
-Vous voudriez
qu'on vous aide
à partir ?
Musique mélancolique
-Dans le débat,
les représentants
des soins palliatifs ont toujours
combattu les partisans
de l'aide active à mourir.
Une opposition qui n'aurait pas
lieu d'être, selon le député.
-Les soins palliatifs
doivent être confortés,
dans ce pays, et s'il devait
y avoir une loi
ouvrant le droit à l'aide active
à mourir,
pour autant, il faudrait,
si j'ose dire,
dans le même temps,
conforter et renforcer
l'accompagnement
en soins palliatifs
en donnant des moyens humains
et financiers.
-Et c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé en Belgique.
Quand le pays a autorisé
l'euthanasie il y a 20 ans,
il a dans le même temps
renforcé ses services
de soins palliatifs.
-Bonjour, madame.
Olivier Falorni,
député de la Charente-Maritime.
-Directrice de l'association.
-Deuxième rencontre
avec des professionnels
qui interviennent
au domicile des patients.
Une prise en charge
qui a augmenté
ces dernières années.
-L'accompagnement
en soins palliatifs
ne se fait pas qu'en structures
hospitalières,
il se fait aussi
dans les lieux de vie,
et c'est ce que nous voulions
pouvoir échanger avec vous.
-Mais en pratique,
cet accès à domicile
n'est pas assez développé,
d'abord parce qu'il demande
une grande disponibilité
des proches,
mais pas seulement.
-Quand on sort de l'hôpital,
ça devient compliqué.
Les équipes mobiles
de gériatrie, les dispositifs
polypathologie gériatriques rares,
les équipes ressources régionales,
les équipes ressources nationales,
les filières de gériatrie...
Est-ce que c'est pas un des rôles
des élus de la Nation
de simplifier
l'accès et l'accessibilité,
et l'actionnabilité,
pour les Français ?
-85 % des Français
disent vouloir
mourir chez eux, cependant,
une sédation par exemple
n'est quasiment pas réalisable
à domicile.
-Il faut qu'un infirmier libéral
soit disponible minimum
deux fois par jour
pour évaluer la situation,
qu'il soit disponible 24h/24,
et je vous parle pas
du médecin traitant
qui doit être partie prenante,
venir tous les jours
et être disponible 24h/24.
La problématique, elle est là.
-Résultat :
plus on approche de la mort
plus le maintien à la maison
se raréfie.
Et c'est souvent dans les services
de médecine générale
que ces fins de vie se produisent.
Olivier Falorni se rend à l'hôpital
de la Fontaine, à Saint-Denis,
au nord de Paris.
-C'est un étage qui a été refait.
C'est un service
de médecine interne.
Il y a 49 lits.
-Dans ces services,
la loi Claeys-Leonetti
est-elle adaptée ?
Une loi écrite après l'affaire
Vincent Lambert
et la bataille d'une famille
autour du devenir d'un homme
dans un état végétatif,
une loi qui a ainsi inventé
les notions
de directives anticipées
pour respecter
la volonté du patient,
quand celui-ci ne peut plus
s'exprimer.
-Aujourd'hui, est-ce que
ces directives anticipées,
est-ce que cette personne
de confiance,
est-ce que ces notions
sont connues ?
Est-ce qu'elles sont appliquées ?
-Ces directives anticipées
sont censées préciser
les traitements médicaux
à donner ou pas.
Est-ce que le patient accepte
une assistance respiratoire,
une dialyse, une alimentation
artificielle ?
Des notions pas forcément évidentes
à maîtriser.
-J'ai fait le test.
J'ai demandé aux réanimateurs
avec qui je travaillais
de me remplir
des directives anticipées.
Eux ne savent pas répondre
pour eux-mêmes.
C'est encore plus fou
d'imaginer des patients
qui n'ont pas la moindre idée
de ce que peut être la perspective
d'un handicap aussi sévère
ou un séjour prolongé en réanimation
puissent avoir
un arbitrage éclairé
sur quelque chose
dont ils n'ont pas la mesure.
-Moins de 10 % des Français
ont aujourd'hui rédigé
leurs directives anticipées.
-J'ai dû avoir cinq patients
qui se sont présentés,
dont les proches ont présenté
des directives anticipées.
-Ce jour-là, tous les services
de l'hôpital sont représentés,
réanimation, neurologie,
pneumologie, et tous souffrent
du manque de moyens.
Dans le service
de gastro-entérologie,
beaucoup de personnes
en fin de vie
atteintes de cancer.
-J'ai un service de 30 lits.
C'est beaucoup.
La nuit, j'ai une infirmière
et une aide-soignante
pour 30 lits.
Donc autant vous dire que quand
ne serait-ce qu'un patient
va mal,
c'est très difficile,
pour l'infirmière
et l'aide-soignante,
qui vont être seules, la nuit,
d'être présentes,
d'être à l'écoute, de répondre
à toutes les demandes.
-Un témoignage qui sera
un des piliers
du rapport qu'a remis
la commission d'évaluation
de la loi Claeys-Leonetti.
-Ce qu'on retient, évidemment,
c'est l'appel d'un certain nombre
de soignants.
Pour appliquer une loi,
quelle qu'elle soit,
et celle-ci peut-être encore plus
que les autres,
il y a besoin de ressources,
et de ressources humaines.
-Même si les députés
n'étaient pas mandatés
pour se prononcer
sur l'aide active à mourir,
ils concluent tout de même,
comme l'avait fait
le Conseil national d'éthique,
que la loi actuelle
n'apporte pas de réponse à toutes
les situations de fin de vie,
notamment quand le diagnostic vital
est engagé à moyen terme.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA